[Musique]
non
donc je disais que moi c'est maya
inoussa et quand j'ai l'occasion je me
présente comme fils de paysan et surtout
si elles veulent être
sauf que ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
j'ai pendant longtemps été fâché avec
l'agriculture puis en pas réconciliés et
ce soir j'aimerais donc vous raconter
cette histoire l'histoire de cette
réconciliation le pourquoi et le comment
alors je dessinais à fada n'gourma dans
l'est du burkina faso donc naturellement
issu d'une famille d'agglo pasteur et
d'un côté il avait mon père clichés de
17 juin à 17h40
je n'étais pas dont il était à la fois
agriculteurs éleveurs mais aussi
commerçants de bétail qu'il exploiterait
le ghana et le nigeria et il était aussi
marchander noix de cola qui va apporter
de ce voyage du ghana et donc ces
messieurs
ainsi à travers ses différentes
activités fait un des mes forces tout
sans jamais avoir mis les pieds dans une
salle de classe et tout naturellement
pour lui il n'aurait aucun intérêt à
inscrire ses enfants à l'école et de
leur côté la mère la même date même
heure or quelques minutes des
différences médical qui a été sorti très
tôt de l'école pour être marié comme
cela s'est passé à son époque et pour l
intérêt absolument à prendre sa revanche
avec l'école à travers ses enfants et
donc c'est ainsi que j'ai été
c'est pour vous dire ainsi qu'ils ont
pigé passé une enfance entre les
cultures sous les armes derrière les
troupeaux jusqu'à ce que j'ai l'âge
d'aller à l'école et on m'a inscrit à
l'école pas pour que j'apprenne à
devenir un meilleur agriculteur mais
surtout que je ne suis pas agriculteur
s'il apparaît totalement paradoxal dans
un pays qui se présente comme un pays
essentiellement agricole à l'école et 7
appris à écrire à lire et à écrire mais
j'ai aussi appris le mépris pour
l'agriculture depuis l'école primaire il
y avait une journée qui était
extrêmement réduite et par moi et
d'autres camarades donc fils
d'agriculteur c'était se joue en début
d'année scolaire les anciens devait
recenser les professions départ c'était
extrêmement pénible d'élever son doigt
pour dire ici fils de cultivateur parce
que pour le reste de l'année
j'étais obligé de moqueries et de ribéry
dans la cour de l'école un peu partout
et même en classe espèce de fils de
paysan c'était l'une des pires ainsi les
prises insupportable auxquels il fallait
faire face et très souvent et aussi à la
fin de chaque année scolaire la classe
était régulièrement divisés en trois
groupes
on avait imprimé goût qui était
constitué de ceux qui du fait de leur
très bon résultat donc passer en classe
supérieure
elle se voit un deuxième groupe
constitué d'élèves qui devaient
redoubler donc reprendre la classe parce
que
la veille des résultats insuffisants et
un troisième groupe qui était constituée
d'élèves que certains enseignants et
mais qualifié remis à leurs parents pour
emploi au chant et donc voyez vous la
grande île moi j'ai grandi avec cette
conception que l'agriculture était
réservé effectivement à ceux qui avaient
échoué à l'école et donc état et a été
inscrit à l'école ma mission c'était de
tout faire pour n'est pas finie
agriculteurs je me souviens de cette
agricultrice que j'ai rencontrés lors à
callas en 2012 lors du tournage d'un
film documentaire qui de toute sa
sincérité exprimé le voeu de voir un
jour que sa fille devienne autre chose
car agricultrice elle disait je cite je
souhaite que ma fille devienne
enseignante ou infirmières j'irai à la
séance est déjà quelque chose par
rapport à la culture
parce qu'au moins elle pourra donc
revenir la neige pendant les périodes
difficiles et donc cette agricultrice
qui étend donc dans le métier nous
laisser ce secret espoir de ne pas voir
sa présidente et le lui a emboîté le pas
si on fait rapidement une comparaison
avec d'autres professions est médecin
il est toujours fier quand l'un de ses
enfants décident de devenir comme lui un
avocat s'arrange toujours pour préparer
au moins un de ses enfants à lui sur le
pas à lui reprend le câble la mède à le
cabinet plus tard et agit mal c'est
parmi les enfants les plus brillants
donc on choisit pour le préparer à sur
le chemin de papa et chacun d'entre nous
ici a certainement au moins une fois
assisté à une de ces conversations très
intéressante où on demande à un enfant
mais lionel qu'est ce que tu veux
devenir qu'est ce que tu veux faire
quand il sera grand et le petit
illuminé inspiré le projet devenir
docteur comme papa pour soigner les
malades à l'hôpital
les pertes ou jayer et puis à troquer
l'enfant il brilla il est ambitieux
alors imaginons une autre scène où voilà
on demande à moussa fils d'agriculteur
qu'est ce que tu veux devenir quand tu
seras grand régional on ne demande même
pas parce qu'on se dise s'il est déjà à
l'école s'est déjà vu c'est déjà un
exploit
qu'est ce que tu veux devenir candidat
grain qu'ils osent répondre je vais
devenir agriculteur comme papa tout le
monde conviendra que c'est un enfant qui
manque d'ambition invisble ouais t'as
aussi moussa
s'il te plaît le wild nicole la société
nous a tous appris à mépriser
l'agriculture à maîtriser les métiers
d'art culture et aujourd'hui encore tous
ceux qui se lancent dans cette activité
sont perçus comme ceux qui n'ont pas pu
réussir à l'école c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
pu décrocher un emploi la fonction
publique c'est qu'ils n'ont pas pu
décrocher un emploi dans le secteur
privé
et c'est pas une réalité propre burkina
faso j'allais que c'est l'une des
réalités les mieux partagées en afrique
ma génération aujourd'hui a
définitivement tourné le dos à
l'agriculture et cela a des conséquences
dramatiques
on estime aujourd'hui à l'afrique à
l'âge moyen des agriculteurs à plus de
50 ans cinquante ans
et au même moment plus de 70% de la
population du continent âgé de moins de
30 ans qu'est ce que ça veut dire très
rapidement on a une minorité de
personnes âgées qui produit pour nous
les majorité des jeunes qui est pourtant
confronté au chômage c'est pas paradoxal
le niveau du chômage et du sous-emploi
sans précédent et malgré cela à coire
beaucoup de chiens qui se console qui
préfèrent encore à cette situation de ce
mal que d'oser un jour finir
l'agriculteur mieux vaut être super
calculateur vous êtes d'accord on peut e
et on dit aussi que dans 25 à la
population du continent africain va
doubler donc cette minorité de
personnages et devra nourrir deux fois
plus de bouche on peut alors
légitimement se poser la question qui va
nourrir l'afrique d'ici 25 ans quand
donc ces populations agricoles déjà âgé
et sous le poids de l'âge ne pourra plus
pour dit absolument c'est la jeunesse de
janvier les deux mais qui devra donc
travailler à nourrir l'afrique et pour
cela je pense il est absolument
nécessaire à travailler pour réconcilier
la jeunesse africaine avec les métiers
d'agriculture et à au moins trois
raisons pour cela
la première raison c'est que le secteur
agricole dégage énormément
d'opportunités dont les jeunes dont la
jeunesse africaine aujourd'hui peut
tirer profit
deuxième raison
l'agriculture africaine a absolument
besoin de sa jeunesse au prendre le
relais de cette population agricole
vieillissante et troisième raison
les jeunes affectés aujourd'hui qui sont
de plus en plus instruits qui sont de
plus en plus ouvert au monde qui ont de
plus en plus accès aux technologies
peuvent facilement apporter les
innovations nécessaires pour changer le
visage de l'agriculture africaine au
moins trois raisons
et donc pour cela avoir il faut
travailler à réconcilier cette jeunesse
avec l'agriculture est l'une des choses
qu'il faut absolument faire c'est déjà
travaillé à changer cette perception
négative changer l'image de
l'agriculture et c'est l'ambition que
j'ai choisi de porter il ya quelques
puits avec une équipe de jeunes
professionnels africains à au moins 12
pays africains
ensemble nous avons créé une web télé
qui s'appelle agri business team et a
travaillé une plate forme à travers
laquelle nous essayons donc de raconter
il nous dit sera de l'agriculture
africaine
les médias nationaux ou internationaux
habituellement ce qu'il nous raconte pas
exclusivement c'est surtout des
histoires autour des inondations la
famine mais nous nous avons choisi de
montrer l'image de cette argutie à tous
les jeunes de par leur courage
introduisent des innovations vont
changer le visage de ce secteur
nous identifions des jeunes avec un
parcours suffisamment intéressant et
nous essayons de raconter leurs
histoires à travers de courtes vidéos
qui nous diffusons à l'encontre à
l'andra dans d autres jeunes en espérant
que ces histoires positives
puissent les essayer au moins pas la
mission n'est pas d'amener tout le monde
pour les jeunes à se lancer dans
l'agriculture
au moins on puisse changer cette
perception chalet notre égard sur
l'agriculture pour que demain
les jeunes agriculteurs puissent
fièrement se présenter parution bonsoir
moi aussi agriculteur communauté comme
aujourd'hui olivier brossard et ses
pilotes
bonsoir et ses architectes donc c'est
l'ambition que nous avons choisi de
procréer et cela commence à produire un
certain nombre de résultats qui est déjà
moi dans mon entourage immédiat de
gilles des promotionnaires avec qui donc
j ciel contact et à travers ses
différentes donc production qu'ils
arrivent à voir j'ai toujours quelques
uns qui commence à me dire ah j'ai
commencé une ferme avicole en contact
avec ça que les gars commencent déjà à
charger et si tout positive
c'est un travail de longue haleine et
c'est une ambition qui forcément nous
dépasse et nous avons décidé de jouer
notre partition
il ya effectivement des jeunes qui sont
en train de travailler à changer l'image
de l'agriculture à la flip et je
voudrais vous donner quelques exemples
lui c'est alphonse sépare du burkina
faso il a été à l'université il a fini
il a eu sa maîtrise en sciences
économiques mais alphonse aime bien dire
à qui veut bien l'écouter c'est grâce au
port qui sépare arriver à payer sa
scolarité et donc tout naturellement
après ses études à l'université il a
décidé de travailler à moderniser cette
activité familiale qui est l élevage de
porcs en introduisant quelques
innovations et l'une d'elles s'est déjà
introduit des races améliorées qui sont
plus adaptés à la bouche possible ou
encore de convaincre ses parts a dit
l'une de ses difficultés c'est est de
convaincre justement s'enferrer savait
que le port avait aussi droit à une
maison propre
ou encore qu'il prendra même eu aussi
droit à une meilleure alimentation
une alimentation plus contrôlé bagis
ouvrit l'ampleur et laisser le port
toute la journée chercher ce qu'il l'a
trouvé ce qu'il doit chercher pour
manger mais c'est tout l'entretenir les
soyez le nourris convenablement et c'est
l'un des moyens les plus sûrs pour doc
que ça puisse rapporter gros je voudrais
aussi vous présenter grâce marlène dubé
n'est elle a étudié les relations
internationales dans une université au
canada puis elle est rentrée dans son
pays est contre toute attente au lieu de
chercher d'autres cas régente le
ministère des affaires étrangères de son
pays elle a décidé de se lancer dans
l'agriculture biologique et sa ses
parents ne l'attendait pas de cette
oreille
mais à perth et vira au bout de quelques
années elle a su convaincre elle a su
apporter la preuve que c'était aussi un
chemin par lequel pouvait
personnellement trouvé son bonheur
puisque c'est la chose la plus
importante
chaque individu a droit de pousser au
son bonheur je voudrais aussi vous
présenter axel emmanuel de la côte
d'ivoire il a travaillé pendant quelques
années dans une banque puis un jour il a
décidé de tout quitter pour se lancer
dans la transformation du cacao en
chocolat de manière artisanale
c'était sa passion il dit pourquoi les
chocolats c'est déjà parce que la côte
d'ivoire son pays est le premier
producteur mondial de cacao plus de 70 %
de la production mondiale vient de la
côte d'ivoire et au même mois quand vous
regardez - à peine 5 pour ça la
production est transformée localement
pour lui c'était une règle qu'il fallait
corriger
d'où son engagement dans ce sens et
aujourd'hui il arrive à employer une 10
deux personnes donc simple employé dans
une banque aussi car qu'ils fissent
révélé devenu aujourd'hui il conduit une
structure donc de production artisanale
de chocolat qui emploie une dizaine de
femmes en multipliant les innovations
comme former les femmes donc d'aller
zone de production du cacao à
transformer directement leur production
à chocolat pour avoir une plus value
4ème exemple je voudrais vous présenter
à la cabane de signal elle a étudié
l'informatique un diplôme d'ingénieur en
informatique qu'à la fin de ses études 6
après la donc l'université associé avec
ça flingue de ses camarades
ils ont décidé de créer une plateforme
qui permet aujourd'hui à des femmes
rurales sénégalaises d'accéder à de
nouveaux marchés de vendre leurs
produits agricoles transformés à un
nouveau type de clientèle
la classe moyenne comme preuve le dit
consistaient essentiellement des
citadins qui malki qui sont plus soucier
de ce qu'ils consomment
dès l'origine que la qualité est aussi
qu'ils sont à la richesse et qui n'ont
pas toujours le temps donc de faire le
tour des marchés pour trouver les
projets et produits locaux vous allez
pour venir avec moi que très souvent il
est plus facile d'endommager les trouver
un produit qui vient de chine qu'un
produit donc qui a été transformée par
dans les femmes de l'ombre pour ne pas
aller plus loin et donc tous ces jeunes
il y en a beaucoup d'autres exemples que
je pourrais passer toute la soirée a
cité mais j'ai passé tant en vain pas
m'arrêter là entre temps tous ces jeunes
travaillent à l'umq a changé l'image de
la les secteurs agricoles africaines à
travers les innovations parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont été à l'école et
ils ont accès aux technologies et ce qui
m'amène à cette conviction finale qui
est que l'avenir de l'afrique et de sa
jeunesse
intimement liée aux progrès que l'on
réalisera dans les domaines agricoles je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]